trailer Matt wall show a violent mob of
trans activists assaulted and harassed a
campus speaker last night they even
chased her into a room and held her
against her will otherwise known as
kidnapping this happened on the same day
that news breaks of another trans
terrorists who had planned attacks on
schools and churches in his area
trans-terrorism is becoming a major
problem in our country we need to talk
about it also Republicans in the
Tennessee legislature voted to expel two
Democrats who led an Insurrection in the
capital it's great to see Republicans
actually fighting back for a change and
a new study shows that a rapid rise of
ADHD is occurring among adult women in
this country it's also rising in all
other age groups is that because there's
some kind of mysterious mental illness
going around or could there be another
explanation we'll talk about all of that
and much more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
has been overturned and this battle is
now finally leaving DC and going to the
Grassroots as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in a post-real
America with about 1 million Volunteers
in 1500 cities 40 guys for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities because of that they actually
have a larger presence in Blue State
specifically California former former
abortion clinic directors say these
vigils can cause the abortion no show
rate to go as high as 75 percent which
is detrimental to their abortion
business these law-abiding vigils have
helped close abortion facilities in San
Francisco Seattle and Chicago and many
other places they're also leading the
way to efforts for efforts to prevent
pharmacies from dispensing chemical
abortions and you can join their crucial
work support their work and check out
their locations and podcasts and free
magazine at 40daysforlife.com the fight
for life is certainly not over in fact
it's never been more important so you
got to get involved we all do for more
information on 40 Days full life go to
40daysforlife.com
it is sometimes said by some on the
right that the fight to protect women's
sports and to defend the privacy and
safety of women in their locker rooms
and bathrooms must be fought primarily
by the women themselves or only by the
women themselves you know if they're not
going to defend their own spaces then
there's nothing the rest of us can do
the logic goes but I've always felt this
line of thinking is a pathetic cop-out I
mean it's something said by people who
are trying to excuse their own inaction
it's the rationalization of cowards yes
women need to speak up
yes it's true that not enough of them
are but it's not the primary
responsibility of young women in college
and high school girls to beat back the
march of gender ideology okay that
cannot fall on them to do we can't leave
them alone on the front lines because
this is what happens when we do that
post-millennial reports quote on
Thursday night swimmer and women's
sports Advocate Riley Gaines was
assaulted by radical trans activists
during a turning point USA event at San
Francisco State University
after allegedly being physically
assaulted by a protester while she was
escorted to a safe room protesters
followed gains and continued to harass
her quote the prisoners are running the
Asylum at sfsu games wrote on Twitter
along with footage of the incident this
is proof that women need sex protected
spaces still only further assures me I'm
doing something right when they want you
silent speak louder I'm okay currently
but an hour and a half later I'm still
barricaded in a room with ambushers on
the outside yelling and threatening
violence Gaines told the post-millennial
as police escorted me out of the event
space to my current location I was hit
physically twice by what I presume was a
male individual this only assures me I'm
doing the right thing
indeed it should you know you can't ask
for a more profound confirmation of the
righteousness of your cause than to be
chased off of a college campus by a
crazed pack of screaming leftist zombies
that's exactly what happened to Riley
Gaines footage captured amid the chaos
shows Riley running down the hallway
while being chased by this violent
screeching mob watch
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
grab my entire human rights
[Applause]
yes
now this is what uh Riley gets for
taking the provocative position that men
are not women and shouldn't be allowed
to disrobe in front of women in their
locker rooms or compete against them in
their sports leagues okay so if you're a
woman and you say no I don't want to be
I don't want a man uh disrobing in front
of me
this is how you'll be treated she's
defending logic and human decency in its
most basic form
and for that these people want to kill
her
this is what any young woman who speaks
up will face is it any wonder why so
many choose to stay silent
like they're just there aren't that many
people who are willing to potentially uh
deal with something like that and that's
men women it doesn't matter you know if
you're a man or woman no matter what age
you are
most people are not willing to put
themselves in that position in fact most
of the people who say well it's up to
the women to stand up I I'm not gonna
most people saying that would never put
themselves in that position they don't
have the guts to do it
Riley's ordeal wasn't over the mob
stayed outside the room refusing to let
her leave the student newspaper the
Golden Gate Express captured video of
the mob discussing what to do next and
this again is why Riley while Riley is
barricaded inside of a room and they're
outside the room
and listen to what they're saying
and what we're hoping to do is to keep
things peaceful and make her lose her
flight
[Music]
so we could get paid for it too on a
public campus
make her pay us he said
so they are holding a young woman
against her will and demanding payment
okay that's not just unlawful detainment
that's straight up kidnapping legally
speaking
that that's that's a felony you actually
are not allowed to do that according to
the law I don't know if you knew that
but you can't gang up as a mob and keep
somebody barricaded in a room
um with the implicit or direct threat of
violence
Riley should pursue criminal charges
against every student in that hallway
every single one every single one should
be expelled and arrested anyone who
happened to be standing in that hallway
and was on the side of the of the mob
all of them
should have their lives destroyed
that's where we are okay that's what we
should be advocating for all the
students in the hallway should have
their lives destroyed because of this
this doesn't stop
until that becomes the consequence
she needs to sue the school as well and
I I would be happy and I've already had
said this on on Twitter I'd be happy to
give her money to help fund that effort
because the school needs to be needs to
be sued also they allowed this to happen
they put her in this position those
students were outside of the hallway for
apparently over an hour or more
they weren't escorted out what the hell
are the police doing what a campus
security what's anyone doing they're
allowing them to stand there
you've got a mob of people who are who
just chase this woman into a room and
are refusing to let her leave
and the cops are just standing around
like oh well what are we gonna do about
it
so I'll help it any way I can everyone
responsible needs to pay for this and
they need to pay dearly for it
as it happens this attack occurred only
a few hours after news first dropped of
another potential trans-terrorism attack
that was thwarted by police at the last
minute the daily wire reports quote law
enforcement officials in Colorado have
arrested a transgender individual with a
Communist Manifesto for allegedly
planning mass shootings at schools and
churches in the area news of the arrest
was made public on Thursday afternoon
but the arrest happened on March 31st
just a few days after a transgender
terrorist massacred six people including
three children at a private Christian
school in Nashville the individual who
the daily wire is not naming to the
company policy about not getting
notoriety to mass Killers or those who
allegedly aspire to commit such
atrocities is a biological male who goes
by a different uh female name and uses
she her pronouns the 19 year old was
charged with criminal attempt to commit
murder in the first degree to accounts
criminal mischief menacing and
interference with staff faculty or
students of educational institutions the
suspect allegedly targeted Timberview
Middle School Prairie Hills Elementary
Pine Creek High School and other targets
were churches KRDO reported
a family member turned the suspect into
police telling 9-1-1 that they had
threatened to shoot up uh schools and
had severe anger issues a spokesperson
for the 18th Judicial District
Attorney's office told local media that
the suspect was in the process of
transitioning police said the home had
trash piled up all around the house to
where it made it hard to walk and there
were numerous containers filled with
half-eaten food with mold growing inside
and numerous alcoholic beverage
containers laying around the house
suspect also allegedly punched holes in
the wall inside the house and ripped a
door off the hinges
okay so this was a
severely Disturbed person
living in filth and squalor prone to
Violent rage
yet his doctors despite the fact that
he's a general mess of a human being and
obviously deeply troubled
still apparently took his gender
identity quote unquote seriously which
is how he was able to begin his
transition
yes everything else about this guy is
bizarre and disordered but when he says
he's really a woman well now that is
obviously a lucid and sober insight into
his own true nature
but once we got a gender transition
which is supposed to make somebody happy
and fulfilled and uh and just make their
lives better utterly failed
rather than being happy and fulfilled he
was homicidal
fortunately this trans terrorist was
foiled before he could carry out his
plans unlike the one here in Nashville
but we're still left with two
planned trans-terrorism attacks one
prevented one knot
in the span of two weeks two of them
and in between the Covenant attack and
the news of this other attempted
Massacre we've seen trans mobs storm
State Capitol Buildings assault peaceful
counter protesters topped off by a
violent mob a costing a a campus speaker
and holding her hostage
[Music]
trans violence that we've seen in just
two weeks
all while
the government at the highest level does
everything it can to pour gasoline on
the fire here's the latest with that
this has been one of the worst weeks for
of 2023 so far in terms of anti-lgbtq
bills becoming law in States Across
America according to the Human Rights
Campaign more than 50 percent of
transgender youth in the U.S which is
estimated to be more than 150 000 kids
live in States in which transgender
youth have lost access to or at risk of
losing access to gender affirming care
look this is awful news we'll be very
clear about that
lgbtq I plus kids are resilient they are
Fierce they fight back they're not going
anywhere
and we have their back this
Administration has their back
we are so proud of the kids across this
country who have organized protest and
school walkouts to tell the politicians
in their states to stop this legislative
bullying
got to keep fighting this is also uh it
was a really really hard it's been a
hard couple of weeks for Trans people I
mean you know you got trans people
assaulting and killing people but it's a
really hard week for them
now these these uh the White House and
the Democrats they know what they're
doing
they know what they're encouraging
Democrats look at what happened to Riley
last night and their only regret is that
she made it out alive they wish that she
was dead and that's what we have to
understand the left nose
that it cannot intellectually defend its
position on this topic not because not
because they're too stupid to defend it
I mean many of them are stupid but but
because it's impossible to defend the
whole ideology is nothing but
unintelligible gibberish and they know
that and they see what happens when
anybody on their side attempts to defend
it I mean they see for example what
happened to the people who tried to
challenge me at New Mexico State
University this week and and they see
how embarrassing it is for them and they
become all the more enraged and
humiliated
and so they're left with a choice right
they can surrender the issue they can
admit they were wrong they can admit
that this is all nonsense
or
they can push their agenda through by
other means
those are really their only options give
up on trans ideology completely
you can do that or you can assault
harass intimidate and kill your
opponents
we know which one they'll choose and
have chosen
trans activists they want us dead they
believe they have the moral right to
kill us the only thing that could stop
them from doing it is fear of punishment
but the system is on their side egging
them on and if none of the students who
assaulted and kidnapped Riley Gaines are
held accountable that will be the final
confirmation that they need
that they can do whatever they want up
to and including the commission of
violent felonies all captured on film
from there all bets are off
which brings me back to what I said at
the top
we cannot leave it to A small collection
of very brave young women to fight this
out this is a fight that involves all of
us
and men in my view should be on the
front lines just as men should be on the
front lines of any battle
if we leave the opponents of this
ideology alone and isolated they will be
easy targets
so we all need to stand up none of us
belong on the sidelines we're all called
to the fight
now let's get to our five headlines
why does great Skin Care in looking
younger have to be only for the ladies
I'm here to tell you it's not thanks to
genucel Skin Care are you like me and
still struggle with those frown lines or
how about those under eye bags and dark
circles from getting up early to sit at
a computer all day I'm just being
relentlessly insulted right now by this
ad copy luckily for you if you're a
hideous Beast like me for the first time
ever genu cells including both the ultra
retinol and Dark Spot Corrector and
their most popular package at
genucel.com
Ultra retinol contains a powerful
retinol alternative that is safe for
your skin they're Dark Spot Corrector
will help reduce sunspots plus you'll
still get genu cells world class under
eye bags therapy to help alleviate
puffiness genucel promises a media
effects and you'll see results in 12
hours guaranteed or your money back have
you ever met a person that just
naturally looks tired all the time well
I have and that's my broadcast engineer
her Jeff he walks around the office
looking like a a zombie most of the time
given that's uh probably due to the fact
that he's always here but still that
appearance is just unacceptable in my
presence I can't even look at him only
one of us is allowed to be puffy and
ugly and that's me so that's why I
forced Jeff to try genucel I said
put the lotion on your skin or you'll be
fired is what I said to him now while
Jeff is uh still tired his skin tone is
smooth and even his skin is less puffy
which is what's important anyway don't
walk around looking like a zombie visit
genucel.com Walsh just save over 70 off
their most popular package every order
subscription includes a luxury gift box
with two free Springtime Essentials just
in time for warmer weather and free
shipping go to genucel.com Walsh
speaking of campuses by the way in a
couple weeks I'll be speaking at the
University of Iowa and um
left us on campus very upset yada yada
familiar story
um but actually there's some some
personal news that has come out of of
this uh this planned event
and I I didn't I didn't want this to be
the way that all of you find out you
know I wish I wish this is not how I
planned it
but I have been outed by The Gazette
newspaper in Cedar Rapids they ran an
article about the controversy and uh and
here's the headline the headline is
University of Iowa to host conservative
transgender commentator Matt Walsh
that's the headline conservative
so
um there it is now you know
and I think the funny thing is that I I
can assume they meant transgender
commentator in the sense that I
commentate on transgenderism like it's
like if you say a football commentator
is someone who commentates on football
um but they phrased it this way because
I can assume they thought that I'd be
embarrassed or annoyed it'd be a way of
like it's like a little subtle not so
subtle dig at me but um if they thought
it would have that effect that that only
shows that they they really don't know
me at all because this is this is
fantastic so I'm transgender commentator
that means
I'm above criticism okay I've got I've
got all the victim points I need
and I'm now I'm just waiting for all the
endorsement deals to roll in
okay where's my Bud Light can
this is uh this is my day one of
Womanhood apparently so I I guess you
know for for uh Dylan Mulvaney it took
you know it took him a couple of weeks
before before the endorsements really
started coming in but uh
yeah I've got dollar signs in the eyes
now it's um this is this is great news
also means that when I go to
uh University of Iowa to give my speech
anyone that comes in protests that that
it now becomes transphobia which which
honestly it already would have been
because even after I was dubbed
transgender commentator uh I was already
as you know the world's leading foremost
most respected and celebrated lgbtq plus
children's author so now I'm adding
transgender commentator to it it's just
it's gay Erasure homophobia and
transphobia to protest me now
all right
um
here's some more good news reading now
from Breitbart it says the Tennessee
House of Representatives expelled two
Democrat members on Thursday days after
those members allegedly broke house
rules via their participation in gun
control protests
Breitbart News reported that three
Democrat representatives were considered
for expulsion those were Representatives
uh Justin Jones Justin Pearson and
Gloria Johnson of the three only Johnson
was spared expulsion and Johnson
apparently was spared expulsion
um
by from what I understand one vote
so Gloria Johnson
it was was was spared was from what from
what I read one Republican didn't go
along with it all the rest uh but
representative Justin Jones was the
first house member to be expelled
Thursday and representative Pearson was
the second uh days ago on April 3rd
Tennessee house Speaker Cameron Sexton
explained that the votes were not about
peaceful protests rather he suggested
the actions allegedly undertaken by
Jones Johnson Pearson broke several
rules of decorum and procedure on the
house floor
The Tennessean reported that Johnson
Jones and Pearson allegedly used a bull
horn as they LED protesters in the
Galleries and several chants calling for
uh gun reform
now this Breitbart article uh keeps
calling it a protest
it was not a protest it was by the
left's own definition and by their rules
it was a it was an Insurrection by their
standards it is an instruction so being
expelled from the house is should be the
least of their concerns the next thing
that should happen is that these people
should be thrown into a prison cell for
at least three or four years
Because by the less definition it was an
Insurrection they led a mob into the
Capitol Building they were using bull
horns on the house floor uh they LED
demonstrations of the household this was
an Insurrection by the left Zone
standards
but even even without the left standards
on this right
um it's also a violation of the rules of
the State House the Tennessee
Constitution gives the house the power
to expel members for disorderly Behavior
they have that constitutional authority
to do so
and this certainly qualifies okay if
this is not disorderly Behavior leading
a mob into the Capitol building with
bull horns I mean if that doesn't
qualify as disorderly and disruptive
behavior then what the hell possibly
could
yeah so the the double standard
hypocrisy with the way that January 6
was handled that's that's good enough
reason to expel these people and hold
them accountable
but without that
we still have the Tennessee Constitution
which gives uh the the authority to
uh enact these kinds of penalties
they violated the rules they behave
disgracefully and disruptively they try
to turn a legislative session
um at best they tried to turn it into a
personal political demonstration for
their own benefit
um you know
that's at best at worst again
Insurrection they were trying to
overthrow democracy
and now their butts are kicked to the
curb because of it and I say Good
Riddance and um and great job to the
Republicans
of course the media and the left the
Democrats I repeat myself are treating
these people as Martyrs
um
and there's many examples I mean every
prominent Barack Obama came out and all
the the White House and AOC they all
issued statements say this is a dark day
it's a dark day in our democracy you
know and as we've seen
A Dark Day in our democracy is when
anything at all happens that Democrats
don't like anything that happens that
they're like it is a dark day in our
democracy potentially the worst day 9 11
all over again and uh and they didn't
like this
they didn't like it because the rules
were actually being applied to them
they're being held to account for a
change it almost never happens and these
Democrats in the Tennessee legislature
they assumed
right and and you can't blame them for
assuming they assumed that they could do
this and get away with it because
they're Democrats they can do whatever
they want
um
now they're making they're trying to
make themselves into Martyrs the
legislators themselves former
legislators should say certainly see
themselves as Martyrs here's a former
representative Pearson on the uh the
house floor
Friday the government decided that my
savior Jesus
a man that was innocent of all crimes
except fighting for the poor fighting
for the marginalized fighting for the
lgbtq community fighting for those who
are single mothers fighting for those
who are ostracized fighting for those
pushed to the peripheral my My Savior my
black Jesus
he was lynched by the government on
Friday
and they thought that all hope had been
lost
all the the outside it rained and it
thundered and everybody said everything
was open it was some black women who
stood at the cross
it was some black women who watched what
the government did to that boy named
Jesus
they were witnesses as you have been
witnesses to what is happening in the
anti-democratic state of Tennessee they
were Witnesses to what was going on and
I got to tell you it got quiet on
Saturday
yes I tell you it was a sad day on
Saturday all hope seemed to be lost
representatives were thrown out of the
State House democracy seemed to be at
its end
seemed like the NRA in gun lobbyists
might win
but all that was good news for us I
don't know how long this is
this guy he literally thinks he's Martin
Luther King Jr he's comparing himself to
Jesus he's he's he is Jesus Christ we
didn't get to the end was he about to so
because Jesus is resurrected on the
third day uh so I guess he was so we can
expect
uh his Pearson's Resurrection as well
he's going to be Resurrected
comparing yourself to Jesus because he
led a mob into the uh into the Capitol
building
which violates every possible rule of
behavior in the Quorum and he's being
punished for it but just like Jesus
people are such clowns okay and um
and that's how they should be treated
just laugh at these clowns
um
and what I appreciate with what the
Republicans did here
holding them to their own standards or
to to any just you know what holding
them to any standard at all like there's
actually a standard of behavior we're
going to hold you people too and you can
cry about it you can say it's racism
shut the hell up we don't care say
whatever you want about it just get the
hell out of this building
um
and they went through with it
and they you know
historically Republicans they would
never do this
they would never do it they would never
do it because they would you know they
would get all the concerned about if we
do this then they'll do it to us and
this is uh we have to think about the
Norms we have to defend the norms
but I think I know I think the
Republicans
in Tennessee realized that um the Norms
are already out the window
and also you're actually defending the
Norms here because it's it is it is in
defense of the norms and basic a sense
of decorum to kick people out when they
lead mobs in with bullhorns
but all that's out the window anyway
and they're the the Democrats are
already going to do everything they can
to punish you and silence you so that's
already going to happen
the only question is whether this is
going to be entirely one-sided
you know you've got Democrats
um
mourning the persecution
of these Tennessee state legislatures in
the on this the same week
when the former president United States
was arrested and arraigned on charges
that don't exist so they are currently
in the process of trying to throw their
top political rival in prison
and yet this is supposed to be
A Dark Day democracy
this is this is this is one of the few
uh Bright Days
in our democratic system that I've seen
quite some time actually
all right I wanted to read uh this too
as well
Caitlyn Jenner slam Nike for turning
woke Thursday over its partnership with
trans Tick Tock star Dylan Mulvaney
seven years after her own
her quote that's I'm reading from the
article is the language they're using
seven years after her his own
collaboration as a trans woman with a
sportswear line Jenner who transitioned
2015 called out the athletic wear
company after Mulvaney unveiled the
brand deal in a series of Instagram
posts Wednesday where she modeled she he
modeled Nike pants at a sports brawl
alert the media I'm entering my workout
Erica we saw Jenner who was recently
named a Fox News contributor called the
brand partnership in Outrage
as someone that grew up in awe of what
Phil Knight did it's a shame to see such
an iconic American company go so woke
we could be uh inclusive but not at the
expense of the math the mass majority of
people and have some decency while being
inclusive this is an outrage
gender did not explain how Nike
partnered with Mulvaney harmed the mass
majority of people but we did stop
trying to erase women in all caps
you know I I have to as I've said before
with this
and there were conservatives that were
sharing these tweets from uh from Jenner
and say Amen yes
look we have a trans person on our side
Jenner's position on this topic is
totally incoherent okay he is the worst
possible Advocate that you could turn to
he's the worst voice that you could
amplify on this
like what what exactly is your complaint
Jenner
with Nike doing a brand partner
partnership with Dylan Mulvaney what's
your complaint
how is it going woke
okay the only complaint you could
possibly have is that Dill Mulvaney is
not actually a woman
and they're celebrating him as if he is
and they're also having a model women's
clothing when he's not actually one
that's the complaint that's the only
reason to oppose it there's no other
reason
if dill Mulaney was a man who identified
as a man
and then it'd be a little bit strange
that their Nike sponsoring some random
tick-tock influencer
but it would not be an outrage it
wouldn't be a racing women
so the only reason to oppose it is that
he's not actually a woman
and yet that's not generous position
Jenner believes that trans women are
women General says that he's a woman
so it doesn't make any sense
there's a it it appears that Caitlyn
Jenner's position is that um his
Womanhood is valid because he says it is
but other people if if they declare
themselves a woman if that's not valid
no there's there's only two ways of
looking at this either biology
determines who's a woman or who isn't or
it's subjective and it's up to each
individual
if Caitlyn Jenner
sees himself
as a woman and is declaring that he's a
woman well then then he is taking the
latter option here he's saying that it's
subjective
which means that you can't you can't
arbitrarily say that it doesn't apply to
Dylan Mulvaney it's totally incoherent
and also look Jenner
there's there's there's
arguably no other uh trans identified
person alive today
who has done more to normalize and
mainstream transgenderism
I don't think there's anyone else you
can point to who's done as much as
Jenner has done
because most of the recipes Dylan
Mulvaney most of the rest of the uh The
prominent trans identified people and
influencers you can name you know they
came along later they jumped on a
bandwagon that was already well on its
way
but how soon we forget back in whatever
whatever it was 2015
uh Jenner Bruce Jenner comes out as
Caitlyn declares himself a woman is
awarded woman of the year
and uh that was uh it was it was the
first time that had been seen on such a
mainstream visible level
I wasn't the beginning of the the uh of
trans ideology of gender ideology but
that that is when it kind of burst into
the mainstream
um
Jenner has never repudiated that as far
as I'm aware
he's never repudiated for that he's
never apologized for that
he's never come out and said you know
what I shouldn't have been awarded woman
of the year I'm not actually a woman
that shouldn't have happened he's never
done that he still wants to be seen as a
woman but he's going to decide
arbitrarily which other trans identify
people get to be in the club
and then you have these dumb
conservatives
who uh who who think that that you know
because he identifies as trans it
automatically makes him um you know a
powerful advocate
you see we have a trans person on our
side
we're not transphobes you're the real
transphobes
I still think that method that that
strategy works it doesn't
um all right
daily wire report
the Arctic Institute issued a call for
researchers to submit papers for a
series examining
heteronormativity in the far Northern
portion of the planet
the nonprofit Think Tank which exists to
develop economic military and health
insurance Health security policy for the
Arctic asserted that queerness and
Indigenous identities in the region have
often been diminished
analysts are therefore assembling a
series of papers called queering the
Arctic
to examine the role of queerness among
native populations
the group said in a press release how
are queer people in the Arctic
challenging well-established systems of
heteronormativity to what extent are
they suffering from societal cultural or
structural shortcomings and how are they
using their resources to overcome them
with these pointed questions we want to
challenge deficiency-oriented
ethnocentric and neoliberal approaches
and invite authors to create a space to
identify hope spots from indigenous and
queer feminist perspectives may it be
artistic academic analytical or
narrative
now we know that the left they are um on
this
cultural colonialist
you know mission
to paint the entire globe and rainbow
colors
to bring the the good news of the the
gospel of wokeness and of LGBT ideology
idolatry to bring it to every corner of
the earth and now they want to bring it
all the way up to the Arctic
because as we've seen on the left
nothing is allowed to just be what it is
nothing is allowed to exist for its own
sake
um everything must be brought into
Conformity under the leftist ideological
umbrella
everything matter what it is
everything's primary
use primary purpose should be the
spreading of
leftism
all right another story here daily wire
the Mandalorian recently surprised fans
with two Cameo guest appearances lizzo
and Jack Black the two actors were
featured in Wednesday's episode
chapter 22 guns for hire
and so lizzo Jack Black appeared on the
Disney Star Wars show the clip of this
um
episode the scene with lizzo went viral
not for the reasons that Disney probably
hoped but let's let's just watch a
little bit of this
despicable we have Paris at the clock to
call it the stiffing slimy I beg your
pardon this planet is unrecognizable
since he arrived
I had a feeling you hated me I'm
disappointed in you commissioner you
served my family well but Captain
Bombardier is the love of my life and I
know his heart is true
sure he's made some mistakes in the past
but who here Among Us has not
is there no room for a little bit of
forgiveness in a galaxy so vast
I am sorry to have disappointed you my
lady
perhaps someday I can earned such
forgiveness
from your grace
for now you
Exile on the moon the moon of paraquat
all right and as for you who's watching
lady
who's watching this
I saw this clip and I real I had to
double check because I honestly first
thought it was a skit I was like an SNL
skit or something and uh and then I
verified no that's that's actually the
show like that's the show it's that's
what Disney is putting out it has the
Cinematic quality of a furniture store
commercial like the guy who made the ad
for uh Bill's Mattress Warehouse down
the street from your house is a more
skilled director and cinematographer
than whoever's responsible for this
utter direct and the actors in mattress
commercials and car dealership
commercials are better also than what
you just saw there
but this this is what we get okay this
is what we get for mindlessly handing
our money over to these Studios who have
been milking the same franchises for
decades and just putting the same thing
out over and over and over again they
aren't even trying anymore they don't
care they they hate we already know that
these Studios hate you
they also they don't respect your
intelligence they think you're an idiot
and will gobble up whatever they spew
out
they know you're going to watch anyway
because uh because of the brand that's
all it is and at this point instead of
watching The Next Star Wars movie or
show you might as well sit for two hours
in your living room staring at the Star
Wars logo on your screen you know
there's no point in watching the actual
because there's no story anymore it that
doesn't matter all of that is secondary
it's simply about the brand you're
watching a brand and when you watch
these shows in these films now you're
basking in the light and Glory of a
brand
and so you might as well there's no
reason to just that's what that's what
Disney should do the next Star Wars
movie
should be two and a half hours of the
Star Wars logo on the screen or maybe
some guy or maybe lizzo sitting on
screen and just saying Star Wars over
and over again
as a story okay as a and I've been
trying to tell you this forever as a
story Star Wars is over
as a brand it's not
because there are still these these
drones who will show up and no matter
what but as a story it's over there's
nothing left
okay it's it we got every every
ounce of story that could be milked out
of this premise it's gone now
all right the utter is is dry it's all
been milked
this cow is spent a long time ago
and of course you know people will say
well the star war it's the Star Wars
Universe there's so many other stories
we could tell in the Star Wars Universe
was I am always saying
no the star the Star Wars universe is
over but the actual universe
yeah the actual universe is Limitless
there are a lot of stories you could
tell in the universe it doesn't have to
be in the Star Wars universe
but don't let that stop you
uh these companies they hate you with no
respect for you they're not even trying
to make quality content but go ahead and
keep consuming it I guess why not
um and finally major headline here
Babylon B Matt Walsh jumps out of the
bushes at Easter egg hunt to inform the
kids that bunnies laying eggs is
biologically impossible
now I appreciated this story this is
like I think it's the fifth or sixth
time I've been uh mocked
ruthlessly by Babylon B
and uh which I which hurts my feelings
deeply of course but I also appreciate
it
but then my second question was
who tells their kids that the Easter
Bunny lays the eggs is that what people
are being told
I never now
yeah this is this is I didn't know
here's the thing I didn't know that this
was the kind of falsehood I needed to
correct so that's the only thing that
this story gets wrong is that I wouldn't
be going up to kids and say you know
Easter Bunny doesn't lay it doesn't lay
eggs because I never knew that really
that's what you're telling is that what
parents are telling kids that the Easter
Bunny actually lays the eggs like a
chicken
the Easter Bunny thing has always been
you know as you know I'm a Santa Claus
apologist you know I I I'm fully on
board with the Santa Claus thing Easter
Bunny's always been a little too weird a
little too disturbing
even when I was a kid I I always thought
that I was kind of like my parents told
me about this big giant bunny that shows
up
and you know leaves a basket somewhere
comes into the house at least
and I I always had so many questions
about this thing where does this thing
come from we don't have the same with
with with uh Santa Claus there's this
whole whole mythology around we don't
have the Easter Bunny so I've always
thought it was kind of strange I didn't
know that that kids were also being told
that this mutant uh sorcerer east bunny
lays eggs I always when I was a kid I
always thought that the Easter Bunny he
has the eggs and it's like in a basket
and he hides them places
the story is getting even more
disturbing than I thought
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
Scott says would you rather only drink
Bud Light or Miller Lite for the rest of
your life that's a it's an impossible
Choice they're exactly the same beverage
I don't think that there's any I mean
there are some people who try to uh
claim that there's a difference they
pretend that their palate is Discerning
enough to tell the difference between
Bud Light Miller Light it's all it's all
exactly the same it's all it's all
the same uh slop
Mark Douglas says we need a wokeness
index that ranks corporations on how
much woke ideology they push then
consumers can make their choices
that'll be a nice resource to have but
you have you know the thing is you need
some force behind it you know you need
some like enforcement mechanisms
otherwise it doesn't matter
so
the on the left
they have organizations like the Human
Rights Campaign and others that have
their own index like corporate equality
index
um
to just to distinguish which
corporations are being the most faithful
to uh leftist Orthodoxy
but then there's also
there it's it there's some bite to it
like they're going to try to punish you
and they're very well funded and they're
going to try to punish these
corporations who
um fall short
the problem that we have like we talked
about yesterday on the right is that we
can you know we can spend all day long
talking about well this company as well
that company's woke
but we don't give them any reason to
care right you have to give the
companies the corporation some reason to
care about the fact that you're calling
them woke and that you're condemning
them
there has to be some
you know it can't just be bark there has
to be some bite to it
uh
another one says I live in a rural
remote area where Bush and Bud are King
my husband does two multiple 30 packs
per week and he's pretty average around
here he's done not with beer but with um
a b and Jack
we'll make our own if we have to two 30
packs that's like
it's like eight beers a day
that's how much sparkling water I drink
in a day probably go through about eight
which is maybe the least manly thing
I've ever said but I think there are a
lot you know right and I've heard this a
lot I don't know about 230 packs a week
thing but for this from a lot of people
that um you know my dad all he does is
drink uh Bud Light and Budweiser yes so
the
if we decided
to make a concerted effort
to single out if we said okay Bud Light
Anheuser-Busch we're going to single
them out
a lot of wool companies but this is the
one that we're focusing on and if we
decided to do that we could really
inflict some Financial damage
because as much as we joke about the
fact that you know only only Boomers and
uh only like right wing Boomers and Frat
Boys drink Bud Light it's it's basically
true that's that's for the most part the
case
so if we can mobilize
people in those groups particularly the
right wing Boomers
um then it would really it would it
would do some real damage
and at least it would put the company in
a position where they've really got a
choice to make so right now there's no
choice at all
they say who who do I want to piss off
do you want to piss off the left or the
right
for Corporate America it's up it's off
the right all day because nothing's
gonna happen
now if they know there's going to
actually be a consequence to it then uh
now they've now they really have a
choice to make
um
striving to be Galahad says I'm a fellow
traveler with Matt on so many issues but
we part radically on the subject of
animals and ecology the meaning of
Dominion in scripture known to every
Theologian and saint for centuries is
stewardship not domination
um it is right and good to care for
nature and especially for animals
I don't disagree with you I don't think
I said anything disagrees with that uh
but we do have
stewardship is fine
but we are the superior species on the
planet
um and so we can make use of the
inferior species
which should not be a controversial
statement this is this is how the humans
This Is How We Exist if we didn't do
that if we didn't do that at all we said
we have no right to put ourselves above
you know animal life we have no right to
do that we have no right to utilize them
in any way than to begin with billions
of people starve in like a week
because there are billions if you take
if you take uh meat out of it yeah it
might be if you're if you're very if
you're if you live in a well-off
prosperous relatively prosperous
civilization in the western world
um you can you can get away with
the vegan lifestyle
you know you can you can but that is
that is a product of privilege
many parts of the world that's that does
it's impossible
yeah when we went to Africa went to
Kenya with the Messiah tribe they they
live they have cattle you know they have
cows and they have goats
and there's not a lot of Agriculture
um there's there's not a lot of farming
that goes on they have cows and goats
and that's how they live
and if if not for that they'd all die
like right away
so it's clear based on that alone that
we have where Superior species on planet
we have the right to make use of these
animals
while at the same time respecting God's
creation it's no different than uh we
have every right to cut down trees like
all the beautiful trees you can see
outside of my uh the studio windows with
rights to cut down trees build a house
that doesn't mean that we should be
gratuitous or wasteful about it it's
like cutting down trees for no reason we
should try to preserve nature as well so
there's a balance there
but that's what it is a balance
we're coming up on almost one year since
I released the groundbreaking
documentary what is a woman exposing
radical gender ideology ideology for
what it's worth and you'd think this
would be ample enough time for people to
come up with an actual answer to the
question but you'd be wrong as I
discovered at the Young America
Foundation q a New Mexico just two
nights ago their answers are still
somehow as confusing and nonsensical as
they ever were after my speech multiple
critics of mine and critics of reality
as well stepped up to the mic in an
attempt to challenge my position they
cited the usual genders of social
construct thing and other long-winded
nonsense when talking to one
self-identified trans woman a biological
male that is I asked a simple very
predictable question you'd think they'd
have an answer for by now uh what is a
woman and here's what the person said a
woman is someone who is included and
respected and seen and participates in
society recognized by other women that's
the answer which is just a long way of
saying a woman is someone who's
identifies as a woman although this
answer is even worse because actually
not only are you is it circular but
you're also relying on
um the the affirmation of other people
it's an external definition
um which is exactly what they usually
say they don't want to do right
well if you haven't yet seen what is a
woman or if you're on the left and still
somehow find yourself confused about
basic biology I have some good news for
you can now get 30 off your daily wire
Plus Membership when you use the code uh
woman at checkout if you've already seen
the film thank you if you haven't or you
know someone who hasn't tell them to
watch it we need to start recruiting
more people back to the side of Truth
and basic reality to watch what is a
woman join now at dailywire.com
subscribe and use the code woman at
checkout to save 30 off your membership
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation I have
the exciting opportunity to jump back up
onto one of my favorite soap boxes as a
new study published this week finds that
ADHD is rising rapidly in our country
especially among women the New York Post
has this report the number of people
diagnosed with attention deficit
hyperactivity disorder ADHD is climbing
steadily in the US especially among
women in new study found while cases
have risen across all age groups the
spike has been most significant among
women the share of females between the
ages of 23 and 49 years of age diagnosed
with the disorder nearly doubled from
2020 to 2022 since 2010 the rates of
ADHD have tripled over all the study
found but the share of patients taking
prescribed medications for the disorder
has remained consistent males have
historically been more likely to be
diagnosed with ADHD but the study finds
uh findings indicate that the gender gap
has been closing over the past 12 years
needless to say this is an incredible
milestone in the fight for social
justice women have smashed through yet
another glass ceiling it's about time if
you ask me alleged mental illnesses
should be shared and enjoyed equitably
and fairly by both sexes I believe that
that's what's best for Society and also
most importantly it's what's best for
big Pharma you know drug companies they
should have the right to monetize the
mental states of both men and women in
equal measure I say
the post continues previous Studies have
shown that females with ADHD tend to
have very different symptoms than males
which could prevent them from getting
evaluated and diagnosed data for ADHD
tends to skew heavily towards
school-aged males Dr Joseph galasso a
psychologist at Baker Street Behavioral
Health in New Jersey told Fox News
digital in a phone interview he was not
involved in the new study girls tend to
fly under the radar as their symptoms
tend to be internalized boys tend to be
more active with overt behaviors that
lead to early diagnoses on the other
hand he said girls tend to fly under the
radar as their symptoms tend to be
internalized instead of hyperactivity
ADHD can look more like depression or
anxiety in females yet more than 8
million American adults are thought to
have ADHD but some Studies have shown
that up to 80 percent of them are
unaware they have the disorder per WebMD
well that's no good eighty percent of
people with ADHD don't know they have it
think of all the people who are
suffering in silence because of that and
by that I mean all of the pharmaceutical
Executives who have been deprived of the
opportunity to sell drugs to that large
portion of the potential Market really
must be hard for them
but it's not just adults who are seeing
a rise in ADHD obviously the disorder
quote unquote is of course especially
prevalent among children in the 1980s
back with ADHD or add at the time was
first added to the DSM the diagnostic
statistical manual mental disorders was
added in I think in 1980. and during
that decade around one in 20 children
were diagnosed today that number is one
in nine and Rising all the time
that means that more than 10 percent of
all children in the country have been
labeled with this alleged disorder and
the labels being stuck on kids at early
and earlier ages you know we're now told
that kids as young as three years old
can be diagnosed ADHD a decade ago the
American Academy of Pediatrics changed
the medical guidelines to now recommend
psychiatric drugs
for kids starting at four potentially if
their symptoms are quote debilitating
a third of kids with ADHD are diagnosed
before the age of six
so kindergartners are being diagnosed
and drugged teenagers are being
diagnosed and Drug adults are being
diagnosed and drugged this epidemic has
been sweeping the nation for decades and
has only gotten exponentially worse as
time goes on more and more people are
labeled mentally ill and put on
methamphetamines we increasingly become
a nation of drug addicts the
pharmaceutical companies rake in
billions and billions of dollars yet we
rarely stop to talk about
any of this really
um or even or even ask the most basic
questions about it
the psychiatric industry and the
pharmaceutical industry have conspired
to label entire categories of human
behavior and human thought disordered
and and they've assured us that the only
way to fix the problem is through highly
potent and addictive psychotropic drugs
meanwhile most of us who profess to have
no faith in the pharmaceutical industry
we correctly observe that it's a it's a
multi-billion dollar Behemoth with a
vested financial interest in keeping us
in this drugged out stupor we know from
our experience with covid that these
people will lie directly to our faces
just to get us to put their product into
our bodies
we realize all of that
and yet most of us still refuse to
fundamentally question those the the
basic premise
behind Concepts like ADHD and other
alleged mental illnesses
so we might agree that it's over
diagnosed but we're not willing to
question the the logic underlying the
diagnosis
in fact many people again many of whom
otherwise have no faith in big Pharma or
claim that they don't
will lash out angrily at those of us who
do question big pharma's fundamental
claims about ADHD and similar alleged
mental illnesses
we are in other words a culture with no
faith in big Pharma
and yet also with unquestioned faith in
big Pharma
we can't make up our minds and big
Pharma would say that our ambivalence on
the topic is yet another symptom of ADHD
fortunately they have a drug for that
now let me uh let me offer if I could
in an alternative Theory
could it be
that the ADHD diagnosis is skyrocketing
with no signs of slowing down
because the diagnosis was designed to be
both incredibly vague and also
universally applicable
now to show you what I mean here's a
partial list of symptoms symptoms
quote-unquote of ADHD in children
between the ages of 3 and 12. this is
described by the the Mayo Clinic This Is
How They List It
partial list
failed to play to pay close attention to
details or make careless mistakes in
school work have trouble staying focused
in tasks or play appear not to listen
even when spoken to directly be easily
distracted fidget with or tap his or her
hands or feet or squirm in the seat be
on the go in constant motion talk too
much
have difficulty waiting for his or her
turn interrupt or intrude on others
conversations games or activities
so
you know what exactly is the problem
with these symptoms
well not much other than the fact that
they described literally every child
who's ever lived on the planet I have
never in my life met a child who didn't
fall into all or most of those
categories
okay in fact I'd be much more concerned
about a child who doesn't exhibit these
traits than a child who does
of course the ADHD apologist will assure
you that although the symptoms certainly
do sound like a list of the most common
childhood behaviors and personality
traits it's actually much more nuanced
because they'll point out that there are
other diagnostic criteria for example a
child is only diagnosed with ADHD if he
exhibits these traits in more than one
situation so not just at school but at
home and at school
so if he acts like a normal child in two
places well I mean that's a you know
then clearly is ADHD also if the
symptoms are persistent
so they have to the symptoms have to be
observed for six months or more to
Warrant an official diagnosis okay so if
your child is is fidgety and talks a lot
for more than six months
ADHD
see these nuances quote unquote do not
at all change the fact that the symptoms
of ADHD are merely descriptions of
normal childhood characteristics
it is normal
and as you know I say this is somebody
with six kids
it is normal for a child to exhibit all
of these behaviors and to exhibit them
for years let alone six months
it is normal for a child to be this way
at home to be this way at school to be
this way when you try to take them out
to a restaurant to be this way
everywhere
it may not be convenient for parents or
teachers it may be a nuisance it may be
stressful to deal with sometimes that
doesn't make it a disease
and and this is what the ADHD diagnosis
is it's it's our way of talking about
and describing a set of behaviors and
character traits that we find burdensome
or inconvenient
that's that's what it is
it's just our way of categorizing this
set of behaviors that are that get in
the way of other things we're trying to
do
um and you notice
for all the people that say oh it's a
it's a valid medical diagnosis just like
having cancer or anything else it's just
like any other medical condition
oh yeah well what other medical
condition
what like valid physical medical
condition is diagnosed this way what are
the medical condition do they diagnose
by looking at your behavior exclusively
and then also trying to determine
whether or not that behavior causes
problems in certain environments
you know if you are concerned
that your child
um you know has diabetes
they're not gonna ask you uh uh
questions about whether it causes
problems in in home at home or in school
they're going to run physical tests to
see if they can find it
well but you can find ADHD in brain
scans they say well that's not true and
also they don't
do brain scans
okay if it was if it was just well
there's an ADHD brain and a regular
brain that's like well why don't they
they do brain scans to diagnose ADHD why
don't they do that
what about ADHD in adults the Mayo
Clinic lists these symptoms
impulsiveness disorganization and
problems prioritizing poor time
management skills problems focusing on a
task trouble multitasking excessive
activity or restlessness poor planning
low frustration tolerance frequent mood
swings problems following through and
completing tasks hot temper trouble
coping with stress
um those are those are the symptoms
and these are all indeed difficult
emotions and traits I know from
experience but they are also very human
and very normal in fact once again it'd
be a much greater concern if there was
an adult who did not struggle at least
to some degree with all of these things
a person who never loses his temper or
becomes disorganized that's not a person
that's a robot
now the pharmaceutical companies they'll
acknowledge this point you know that all
of these symptoms are actually normal
but
they'll declare that past a certain
point Beyond a certain threshold
threshold they become abnormal and
diseased well who decides where that
point is who determines the threshold
when they say oh yeah everybody acts
this way but if you act this way too
much
well then it's a disease too much who
says too much
but who decides that it's just like we
saw a symptom for kids it talks too much
who the hell where's the medical
criteria for too much talking
but it sounds pretty subjective to me by
my standards 95 of the planet talks too
much
oh but I'm not I'm not a doctor right
you have to get that you have to get
that uh that you know you have to go to
medical school so that you can find out
how much talking people should do what
who gets to draw the line declaring
exactly how stressed out how
disorganized how anxious how distracted
human beings are supposed to be
well just so happens the people selling
the drugs they get to make that decision
the people prescribing the drugs they
get to make this these are arbitrary
lines drawn by the very people with a
massive Financial incentive to make sure
that as many people are as possible Are
Over The Line
yeah
now am I denying that lots of people in
our culture today are overly distracted
no not at all I'm simply calling to
question the idea that distraction is a
medical condition
I especially call that into question
given that there's another extremely
obvious explanation
why are people so distracted these days
maybe it's because we live in a society
filled with distraction we are
surrounded all the time with screens and
flashing lights and Noise We Carry
little distraction machines in our
pockets we have conditioned ourselves to
Crave constant stimulation children are
plopped in front of glowing screens you
know from their first day on this Earth
so they'll be less of a hassle to
parents who also want to spend more time
on their screens why are people
constantly distracted I mean is that
even a question is that a serious
question how could anyone look at our
society look at the way that we choose
to live our lives and Come Away with the
conclusion that our attention spans are
dwindling because of mysterious mental
illness epidemic
there is a much more obvious explanation
okay and you are staring at it right now
and that is why ADHD
as a medical diagnosis anyway is once
again today canceled and I'll do it for
this portion of shows and move over to
the members block hope to see you there
and if you uh want to join us you can
become a member and use code walls to
check out for two months free on all
your new plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you on Monday have a great
Happy Blessed Easter Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]